hello I'm Dillinger Kapadia and the
manager of calculus and algebra wolfram
and this morning I would speak about
what's new in capital algebra they'll
cover a wide range of topics starting
asymptotic special functions math
education function properties and what
kind of stuff it should be good for
anyone who a student professor research
work anyone so do come along which
should be green thank you okay hello
everyone so I'm given the company I'm
the manager of calculus and algebra at
Wolfram and in this talk I'd like to
speak about what's new in calculus in
algebra
what's happened last one year and this
is a kind of movie presentation I'll
give some brief ideas but then we have a
session to ourselves three talks today
another talk tomorrow
so I'll try and lead into those talks so
I welcome you to stay for all these
talks they should all be excellent so
what I'm giving away is just a brief
overview so here is an outline of my
talk so I'm going to begin with
asymptotic computation which has been a
main theme for the last couple of years
and we have two new functions asymptotic
and discreet asymptotic could be the
kind of super functions they can take
any input function sequence operators
integrals sums etc and they'll do the
right thing so I'll speak about those
asymptotic computation functions and
then about mathematical functions which
include special functions we have these
new hoin function which just a pretty
major advance in our special functions
support and we've done good work on
documentation side will speak about that
differential equations something that
keeps on occupying our time we try our
best to keep up and we always seem to
fall a bit short so that you put a more
little more effort so I'll talk about
that we are very nice programmed for
function properties things like
continuity singularity etc which should
help everyone from it's a pre-college
all the way up to research it's very
deep stuff math education of course is
core to our team I think we are the math
education team in the company from the
mathematical side of things people for
many people
calculus and math America and vice versa
so I speak about math education and one
last
for the last year or so being working on
a linear algebra MOOC a massive open
online course that's ready from my side
it should ship soon
whatever that means so I'll talk about
that so let me begin now with asymptotic
computation so if you have function like
sine X and you want to see what it does
look like near zero let's see of course
you know sine X is approximately X near
0 so you have this nice new function
called asymptotic which will just give
you that leading approximation I'll just
say X for you and so you have a nice
leading approximation but what if you
want one more terms where we have an
option called system goal and you can
ask for more terms so this function by
default will give you a leading
approximation if you want a better
approximation give it the option I'll do
it for you now that's one world the
world of functions but then you also
have the world of sequences so what
happens there well we need a new
function because for a sequence
everything goes to infinity in integer
steps so you have a nicely function or
discrete asymptotic so if there's a
discrete asymptotic of n factorial you
just get back Sterling's formula and of
course that's the starting point fathom
tortex a long time ago we get back the
nice Stirling formula but in what if you
go to the prime sequence so what's the
asymptotic or prime sequence that's n
log N and it doesn't matter it the prime
numbers always we have slightly more
than the n log n but asymptotically the
sequence goes to one so you've got two
functions asymptotic discrete asymptotic
one for functions one for sequences and
of course the question is why do we need
them after all we could just do this in
some way or the other with series well
the point is that we really want to we
had these new functions called
asymptotic integrate an OD solve value
etcetera but it can't keep on doing that
so we need to one or two master
functions in which you can put what you
like and they'll go they'll go and do
the right thing so this asymptotic
function for example can work with let's
say Laplace transform so you have a
function a pretty messy function it's 1
over e raised to tease
theories to power 17 and of course you
may be it could be the plastron who
knows it might take a very long time but
what do you do with it if you got the
answer so what do you do well he
inactivate tell it don't do anything
okay stay where you put inside a central
I go down over here
so that's asymptotic inactive Laplace
transform and lo and behold you get back
in Nice approximation for the Laplace
transform right so you don't have to but
if it didn't have it it might take you
ten minutes for Laplace transform to
tell you I don't know I mean yeah so the
other thing that if it evaluated right
then asymptote knows what to do if it
didn't evaluate it's the same philosophy
as n if you do MF integrate if
integrator worked you're fine if not you
can just an actor with a hole we've kind
of given up on hold because it's it's
kind of programming construct inactive
is much more calculus kind of thing you
can do D of you can do D of inactive
etcetera the inactive is a mathematical
operator in the real sense so we kind of
give up holdest was what we do early on
but an inactive is the way to go now
okay and that's a very nice approximate
but of course you might say I want I
have a generating function for a
sequence what's the asymptotic for the
sequence good the suite I'll do it for
you I wouldn't know the complicity of
karatsuba multiplication will do it for
you so that's a large program we have
got called the asymptotic computation
program and I'll give you a brief idea
about that tomorrow afternoon at 4:00
p.m. so that's one our talks for this
for our team okay so now on to a nother
theme and that's special functions and
math malfunctions so we got these new
functions called Hein functions and what
the hoeing functions are well we have
ten of them and the question is why I'll
tell you in a minute but these horn
functions are great so you learn about
sine cosine exponential in high school
maybe then you learn about Airy Bessel
if you're lucky and if you're really
unlucky you need to study about hyper
geometrics and most of us stop over
there right
for Hoyne hypergeometric SAR a special
case so they encode sine cosine
exponential exit for a hyper geometrics
then encode steroidal functions Lumme
functions
I think the elliptic just about don't
make it over there but basically this
one set super function Hine will swallow
up all the other function into one call
Meiji is okay right right so mayor G is
a generation of hyper geometric and made
you more or less be a special case over
here so this goes beyond mayor G far
beyond that well mayor G is bit
different because it might have higher
differential equations they kind of go
in different directions
but Mayor G's been done for thirty years
and we have the world's expert on Lake
Maracaibo here so mayor G is one
direction and how in a slight different
direction but horn is what people need
when they study quantum computation
nowadays when they do black hole theory
etc so this is the region research in
that area and the question is why the
different from hypergeometric well
hypergeometric by definition have got
three acre singular points zero 1 and
infinity the hoenn functions got a
fourth one at a what's a well the a you
can see over here is a pretty arbitrary
thing and it can be almost anything you
like so that a can want all of a complex
plane and make things very difficult for
us so hoeing functions are really the
major advance for version 12.1 there are
ten of them because you need five point
functions to account for all the
confluence of single era T's then you do
calculate the derivatives so you need
ten functions but once you go to spin
you all set if you understand how
functions ok right ok so but the point
that we really have 250 special
functions since version 1 so what we
thought that the real value for us is to
keep up the documentation of these
functions to a really high level so for
version 12 we added 4,000 new scope
examples
to 200 pages the person worked Ernest
has put in a lot of work Anoosh and was
in 12.1 we said okay let's go back now
and add basic example so now what in
12.1 has got new base examples for all
these functions so for example if you go
to the page for sign in version 12.1
then scroll down a little bit you'll see
that we actually have a nice plot a nice
complex plot from version 12 for every
function so 250 new function pages brand
new from these examples but that's a lot
of work about another couple of thousand
examples over here so and so on the one
hand we got Hein functions at the very
upper end and the low end we got a lot
of documentation improvements so that's
a lot of things to talk about and
there's a nice talk which Tigran has
prepared which is at 12:30 today in the
same room so Tigran is 25 mi say he has
a double PhD it got double PhD by doing
his work and hawing functions he has 12
publications one of rare people who
actually followed his father's footsteps
so his father's an expert on functions
he is one of the world's experts on
special functions I invited to attend
his talk at 12:30 it's his first talk
away please encourage him okay so now
going on to differential equations so
inversion I've always liked this feeling
that you know we are not good enough on
first-order Odie's so for version 12
point we did a survey of calm K and
forth we are not so bad after all but we
filled in all those gaps but the real
value came from using these so called
inactive integrals so you know people
report to us that he got this D Saul
example which might take one hour to
come back or not come back at all what
is happening was that we found one
solution maybe other one of the integral
difficult angle we spent all our time
didn't know what to do so this example
had to various times taken between ten
minutes and one ah
now it takes point 1 1 seconds so just
using inactive integrals made life much
easier for huh
a little bit maybe I could okay I it
might work let me see if that could do
that okay let me see if that might work
ah okay little bit better sure of course
no problem okay so version 12.1 we have
hein functions we need more linear
differential equations the version 12.1
we are filling up the linear
differential equation gaps version 12.2
will be nonlinear and then system or D
but I'm hoping the version 13 cycle will
be on top of the world in differential
equations by our own reckoning so that's
the theme for order differential
equations try and cope open benchmarks
another very popular theme I'm surprised
how popular it is is partial
differential equations so we have some
nice support now for further heat
equation etc we did some work for ten
point three ten point four then we had
done more one version 12 point one so
that's a symbolic solution for the heat
equation the radial equation
it's a beautiful plot over here and
having done this we decided to benchmark
so we have a benchmarking program where
we essentially have one computer which
just chug the wind does millions of tes
examples all the time and every we get
new report so here's one of them which
compares us in various versions ok so ok
open the report up it's a pretty solve
dissolved benchmark it has got 1461
problems and eleven point three you
could do fifty-four percent eleven
twelve point to 66% twelve point one
seventy one percent
maple is now sixty percent below us with
this improvement when it ships simple
eleven percent
I think sage has got no support for P DS
so in this area where we should be
pretty much a top and twelve point one
and how do we judge ourselves so we have
a way of judging the time we take to
solve problems they got interactive well
we got instant time quick a real time
bit slow response of time even slow
in Traktor time background time the kind
of job is not electron while you are
working in the computer and then finally
coffee time so okay so we try and keep
the coffee time down but the computers
need coffee yeah
the answer is that we have a notebook
with the four hundred long she cannot do
I suspect that maybe 125 can be done
the others don't have proper solutions
or they got they might have a particular
solution and the developer keeps on
telling me they know we should return it
with a message I mean I'm really worried
about breaking a design but yes we have
the note look at us and we work on that
so we let's Rogers point is valid we
should be 100% or no why we are 100%
this yeah but this this Oh years I would
say all the examples can be done
reasonably with what we have right now
okay okay so another very nice program
that we've got right now is function
properties so you know you often don't
know is this function continuous what
are singularities is it injective is it
by jected surjective so we have a vast
program very big program it's not quite
ready it's for version 12 point to
if you all know is this function of a
max of log of ABS X plus 1 whatever
whatever
continuous it'll say yes it's true it
will be back in and you can see that
that's correct on the graph but the
difficulty we hide as we go to these
functions called Q so you've got prime Q
and if you ask prime Q what's X
what's prime Q of X is you say false and
that's not correct right because you
don't revert X's so this function C is a
bit cleverer so C over that means
condition so it might give you back a
nice condition in this case set it's if
you go to spunctional-- here clearly
that's going to be continuous of a is
equal to 1 and this over here is a nice
new type sitting for the conditional
expression due to eat i in version 12.1
so you can
back either true or false or a condition
or it might be very honest in say I
don't know which is fine
veterans having false which is not a
false okay so there's a nice talk by
this this is very deep difficult to work
item works on a little create other day
and he speak about today at eleven
thirty right over here okay so now on to
the next theme or year which is perhaps
very important for many people in this
room as well math education so we have
tried a best in version twelve to try
and make the system more usable for high
schoolers college level everyone this
has been a really serious attempt and
for example you got this thing called
add site which you can just add the same
number available to both the sides
I've taught middle school algebra for
many you're littering in a classroom and
I know how difficult it is to teach
algebra the first time but we has a nice
function add sides multiply sides etc
which you can use to motivate students
through the right thing when you are in
the classroom and on the other side I
spoke about special fun documentation we
have completely refreshed pages for
delimit integrate so we did be in 11.1
limit in eleven point two eleven point
three took a break for asymptotics
twelve point to it did integrate but
these plays now have as many example
that you might want to know for a
college calculus student or someone and
we also have these new interface
development so you can figure out
whether the multiplication sign not
implicit in some calculation it's all
getting really very kind of powerful on
the education side but that deserves
another talk and in fact that talk will
be given by ETA today at eleven o'clock
so I think that we really want to keep
going on the education side and make
things much better one last thing that
personally I have I worked on this
introduction to calculus MOOC a couple
of years ago started work we shipped
last year and it always I always
wondered is it really worth my time and
why bother kind of you know
when it shipped and then a few months
later someone from Nigeria lives in a
village near Abuja had to travel two
hours a day to get to school would
scribble Mathematica on his notebooks go
to school tried on computer in their
money for the bus
he sent me certificate said I have done
it it seems to me that this is the best
way for us to reach the world do online
courses so I put in a lot of effort in
the last few months to prepare this new
course interacted in algebra which
basically focus on matrices but also
does vector spaces so you see where your
arthur cayley sylvester kramer piano
gauss they are all then the course it's
a very nice course i think 25 lessons
and you go from two by two equations to
singular value decomposition in 25
lessons and we want to have some more
courses but I want to wait for you tell
us what you want in terms of future
courses so if some thoughts do let me
know and I'm almost done well I'm done
it really so this one summarize and say
that we have a very active development
program readings asymptotic special
functions function properties
differential equations but when Roger
set up the team a couple of years ago we
were never a team really we just loved
to do what hidden a team for that okay
he said let's talk about development
let's talk about documentation
let's benchmark and figure out how good
we are if you're not so good be humble
about it if you're good be proud of it
and finally go out do some outreach
reach the world so that's the kind of
thing we try and do it doing development
documentation benchmarking outreach and
I think it's worked out so well too so
far that we are encouraged to go on so
thank you very much I stopped
you